[Music]
we're the duffer brothers we're the
writers creators directors producers of
the netflix series stranger things
[Music]
in this class we'll use examples from
stranger things
and show you documents we've never shown
anyone ever before you're going to learn
how to develop a television show how to
take it from the seat of an idea to an
outline into a script and ultimately how
you sell that script we actually got
rejected at least 12 times before we
finally sold it in real time we're gonna
develop an unofficial dustin steve
stranger thing spin-off idea this is not
a real thing netflix how about they find
that dustin's dad is missing and has
been missing for many
years
it says
many many many months
this class is for the person who dreams
of telling stories for a living it's
everything we wish someone had come and
told us we think it could give you an
idea of how to get from a to b
yeah i still think it's pretty cool all
right the lizard creature huh we'll see
what the internet thinks
[Music]
[Music]
you